[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
what's up everybody how you doing this
is pete also known as now though here to
give you a
iron lord's podcast first look at skull
bot
games gone viral now they ended up
sending us a key to see if we can do a
little review and do a little game play
on our stream so what i ended up doing
was i ended up
getting us together i got uh a group of
people i knew was that was going to be
able to quote unquote support me in the
game and you'll see why i say it like
that
uh and and we we started to go through
it now um
gone viral is a game that is about a
post apocalyptic world
where a bunch of people have started
doing this type of blood sport
in a underground cavern uh
it's almost like a roguelike fight em up
game
now the reason why it's called gone
viral is because
you get power-ups and you get uh how can
i word it
and your chat will then end up allow you
to
drop in different types of um
upgrades and mutations and things like
that for you to continue to play
in addition to that they'll end up
having you place with other
types of um bad things that'll happen
like
bombs or things like that now
throughout the time that i played my
chat decided
that they were going to be comedians and
drop bad mutations and top drop
bombs and drop multiple different types
of things on top of me
i wasn't a huge fan of it but at the
same time i was happy that they got some
great enjoyment out of it
now that's what this type of game is
about now
uh for the time that i played gone viral
what you end up doing is it's a hack and
slash roguelike
that allows you to get power-ups
throughout the whole entire time you're
going to play
now what you're going to do is you're
going to be fighting you're going to be
killing different monsters you're going
to be using a gun you're going to be
using a grappling hook you're going to
be using a sword
you're going to be able to bash them uh
with your with your you know your
shoulder bash
you're going to have all these different
abilities and all these different things
you're going to get
now what you'll end up finding which is
the most
interesting is that the power-ups in
your health and things like that
they're mostly going to come from your
from your from your chat but they can be
total comedians and give you garbage
which is what ended up happening to me
multiple times
now the way that that works is through a
uh
it's called an audience meter now the
audience meter is going to keep
you know you're going to end up getting
votes on on what you're doing and then
eventually will end up happening is
you'll end up getting enough uh points
to allow you to go ahead and
and get some bombs scattered and get
those those power ups
or those uh the bad power-ups so to
speak
uh you're gonna get the um the bombs or
you're gonna end up getting
uh tornadoes and i mean it's it's a
whole
there's a whole bunch of different
things that i ended up getting so it was
very very unique and a lot of fun
now the the animations on it um you know
they
they are pretty decent uh they're not
you know top of the notch
but uh as expected and you know it was
you know pretty good uh the they were
very fluid animations the
the artist the artistic tree uh of
the of the of the characters are really
well
played out and really really good the
replay value is basically off of what's
going to happen
for your your you know your fans
your people that you're watching your
channel so um once you end up getting
those special events
uh and having fun with that that's
what's gonna make this game
way more worthwhile to continue to play
over and over and over again is the
enjoyment that you're gonna have with
them
now i found it to be really really fun
i i like i said i only played it for a
couple of hours uh
and it was great and and like i said my
chat loved it
i loved it all was great so now uh
it was it was what i tend to have
expected
from a type of twitch based game um
now i i made a couple of runs that were
really
really really really really good and
then a couple i were just like
trash like i could only get two rooms
and done and that was based off of you
know just me
playing around uh trying to get my my
hands uh all together
um it was good so
uh thank you very much for listening
to this um to this review
and uh remember iron lord's podcast is
on every single saturday
lords of gaming.net if you're looking to
get any type of your
you know gaming news which we do uh
regularly all right
so thank you very much and have a
fantastic day bye everybody
all right well clearly we gotta go down
and around the end
shorts out pretty nicely because we can
pick up some more than armor
similar to the enemy pieces you guys do
have for me thank you very much
choose one the bomb batter or
covered in carnage
have a ball oh great let's do
covered in carnage carnage
charges faster
i could work out a national
oh my god are you kidding me right now
that was so many balls
no key
oh my god
dodge faster much faster you got that
right
look at that dodge
oh my god
boss fight gladiator versus
this is not gonna end well
oh my god
heavier and more slowly oh no
that's not going to be good for me
saw me on this game um
so people decide
to add more bonus things going on in
this chat into this
event as you can see above
it is a lot more fun than i thought it
was going to be
and uh
you get to kill stuff
regenerative armor
out levels end it heals all the way
pay to win pay coins for power
okay okay
where is the in the corner
here we go
and what ends up happening is people
vote for things that happen in the
channel
so it's very much a hack-and-slash type
of thing with the room
and then when you guys vote to do things
you can get air drop once you get 100
fans
you get some drops in you got some stuff
it's just pretty freaking nice oh my god
so you guys just voted this to happen
what the frick
i have no idea what you guys just did by
the way
oh i can't
knock stuff back here
so essentially it's kind of like uh
what is it called
oh god
fast feet slow shots okay i'll take that
but like the there's different things
that happen in the room
you can blow some stuff up if you want
lots of different things
everyone bounces oh god
you can use the things around you oh my
god
you hurt people
bombs away you might have seen the
squall by the way at pax east
they did have um a boot there
if you're wondering
your event bombed yeah this is that's
how i got the
the code for it and like i said i have
i have oh my god
so where's the rogue aspect
how's it going do you mean the fact that
you have to
run around it's not a roguelike it's
top-down
kind of like um
diablo so it's like a diablos type game
essentially you have your viewers are
going to vote on if you
what's gonna happen to you
[Music]
you